in this lesson 12.1 we're going to talk
about right triangle trigonometry you
probably learned about this in your
geometry class but we're gonna do a
little bit of review here so when we
talk about right triangle trigonometry
we're working with right triangles which
means that they have a right angle
symbolized by this square here this
representing these two sides are
perpendicular and what you do is you
position yourself at the particular
angle that you're working with and you
think of the side that's across as the
opposite side the one that's next to the
angle but not across from the right
angle we call it the adjacent side and
the one that's a diagonally across from
the right angle we call the hypotenuse
that's the longest side so we're working
with these trigonometric functions and
basically what they are are their ratios
of two sides in a right triangle so for
example when you want to find the sine
of an angle you take the opposite side
over the hypotenuse and there's an
acronym that students you know learn
when they learn sine cosine and tangent
it's this one here it's so
Toa and basically it just helps you
remember you know sine is the opposite
side over the hypotenuse so the cosine
is the adjacent side over the hypotenuse
the tangent is the opposite side over
the adjacent side so if we can remember
this acronym sohcahtoa and just remember
that's the second ladder divided by the
third ladder you'll be able to remember
those trigonometric ratios and the other
three things that you want to memorize
are the cosecant secant and cotangent so
these are the reciprocal functions of
sine cosine and tangent the trouble that
students oftentimes have is remembering
which one goes with which one so they're
just remember the sine and the cosecant
are reciprocals so the cosecant the
hypotenuse over the opposite the sine is
the opposite over the hypotenuse so
they're just they're just flipped the
cosine and the secant are reciprocals of
one another and the tangent the
cotangent so the ones that students
usually make a mistake on are this
cosecant and the secant because they
sound very similar but if you can
remember one of the pairings and you'll
automatically know the other one so
let's get into just an introductory
example to show you kind of how to work
with this say for example we have a
right triangle here in letter
and we want to find the sine of this
angle theta now theta is just a Greek
letter they use Greek letters when
they're talking about angles like alpha
beta gamma you know etc so when we talk
about sine of theta we're talking about
this angle here we're gonna position
ourselves at that angle the sine
remember is the opposite divided by the
hypotenuse so the opposite is one across
that's going to be three over the one
across from the right angle that's the
hypotenuse so the sine of theta here is
going to be 3/5 now if we want to find
that cosecant of theta all we have to do
is just take the reciprocal of what we
got for the sine of theta and it's going
to be 5/3 how about the cosine of theta
the cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse
now remember adjacent next to but not
the hypotenuse see there's two sides
that are next to this angle you want
this one not the hypotenuse so four over
five is the cosine secant is just the
reciprocal so five over four the tangent
is opposite over adjacent so that's
going to be three over four and then the
cotangent is just gonna be the
reciprocal four over three now we want
to learn algebra to check out my learn
algebra 2 video course for sale where we
go through 85 video lessons that take
you step by step by step through algebra
2 we go through the important formulas
concepts as well as numerous examples to
help you master algebra to click the
interactive card or the link in the
description below to go over and check
out some of the free lessons otherwise
let's get back into this current lesson
four over three now when we talk about
right triangles there's a couple of
special right triangles that are they
come up over and over again and we will
be talking about them more in this
chapter and that's your 30-60-90
triangle and your 45-45-90 triangle so
again you probably learn this in
geometry but just to review the ratios
that you want to remember or the
relationships I should say between the
sides are like this the one that's
across on the 30 degree angle that's
going to be the shortest side it's kind
of like they have a small angle you can
see that's opened up just a little bit
the side across from that smaller angle
that's going to be the shortest side so
we call that side X the one across from
the 60-degree angle that side is x times
the square root of 3 so whatever the
short leg is you multiply that by square
root of 3 to get the longer leg now keep
in mind square root of 3 is about one
point seven so it's
about 1.7 times longer and then the one
that's across from the right angle that
side is 2 times X what's double that
shortest leg
so basically when they give you a
30-60-90 triangle like this it's really
easy you just say well if I have the
hypotenuse I divide by 2 to get the
short leg and then I multiply by square
root of 3 if I have the longer leg I
divide by the square root of 3 to get
the short leg and then I double to get
the hypotenuse now the other special
right triangle is the 45-45-90 special
right triangle what's interesting is
because these two angles are the same
the two sides that are crossing goals
are also the same it's an isosceles
triangle right so we call these two legs
acts ok and the one that's across from
the hypotenuse I'm sorry from the right
angle the hypotenuse that's x times the
square root of 2 square root of 2 by the
way is about 1.4 so this diagonal here
is going to be about 1.4 times longer
than either of these two legs if they
give you the hypotenuse you just have to
divide by the square root of 2 to get
back to one of the legs ok so let's look
at some examples regarding those some
introductory examples if we want to find
the sine of 30 degrees what we do is we
position ourselves over here at this
30-degree angle remember sine is the
opposite divided by the hypotenuse so
that'd be axe over 2x so let's go ahead
and write that down and you can see that
X is like 1x these X's actually cancel
out and we get 1/2 so that's what the
value of sine of 30 degrees is now
what's interesting also just to mention
here is that you see I've drawn this
30-60-90 triangle this is a fairly small
triangle but imagine if I was to draw
this you know a gigantic triangle there
was a right triangle it had a 30 degree
angle the sign of that enormous triangle
the ratio of the opposite side and the
hypotenuse would still be 1/2 and that's
the power of trigonometry is that if you
know these ratios you can apply them to
any type of triangle with those same
angle measures okay so let's see if we
can jump into example see here we've got
cosine of 45 degrees 45 degrees remember
cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse see
adjacent divided by hypotenuse so that's
going to be X divided by X square root
of 2 X is like 1x the XS cancel we get 1
over square root of 2 we don't really
want that square root in the denial
so I'm gonna rationalize by multiplying
the top and bottom by square root of two
that gives us square root of two over
square root of four which square root of
4 is just 2 so that's an exact value for
cosine of 45 degrees we're gonna be
using these values as we go through this
chapter so let's look at example D and E
here so here we want to find out what's
the missing side length here okay so
what we need to do is we need to figure
out well you know what trig function
ties together this angle this side and
this side so we position ourselves at
the angle we say they're giving us the
adjacent side next to in the hypotenuse
okay so adjacent hypotenuse that's
cosine so we've got cosine of 50 degrees
equals adjacent divided by the
hypotenuse which is 12 so now all we
have to do to get X by itself this
missing side length is to do the
opposite of dividing my 12 multiply both
sides by 12 but those cancel and you've
got 12 times the cosine of 15m okay I
wanted to show you on that calculator
where some of these trig functions are
you can see on the ti-84 the right here
in the middle it's a sine cosine and
tangent and notice right above them to
see the sine minus 1 cosine minus 1
these are the inverse trig functions
we're gonna use those in a future lesson
here to solve for the missing angle but
for right now we're gonna be using sine
cosine and tangent one thing I want to
be careful of before you use these is to
go to your mode here see this mode and
what you want to do is you want to make
sure that you've selected degrees okay
so if it's on radians just go over to
degrees press ENTER in the lower right
hand corner and then press 2nd quit that
takes you back to the home screen here
so in the last example we were working
with 12 12 times the cosine of 50
degrees so let's see what that comes out
27.7 so this gives you know you know the
answer here we just around it a little
bit to the to the 10th but you can run
into the hundreds etc so that's how you
calculate it on your calculator again
just make sure you in degrees and and
you got it okay great so let's look at
example email so here we can do this one
now two different ways one we can either
use the special right triangle the
30-60-90 triangle or we can use our
calculator and use the sine cosine
tangent functions let's go ahead and use
the special right triangle first
so you can see that they're giving this
angle 30 degrees they're giving us the
hypotenuse which is our 2x side if we
divide by 2 that means that X is going
to be 5 and if we want to find the
longer leg we just have to multiply by
the square root of 3 so that means that
y equals 5 square root of 3 now the nice
thing about square root of 3 here is
this is like an exact answer if we do it
on the calculator we're gonna get like
an approximate value we'd have to round
it so the other way to do it is let's
say I wanted to solve for X here I would
say sine of 30 degrees so that's where
we are right here at this angle okay and
we've got the opposite side which is X
just pretend we don't know that for a
moment over the hypotenuse which is 10
so all we would have to do is multiply
both sides by 10 and you've got 10 times
the sine of 30 do that on your
calculator and you'll get 5 so that's
how you would work with it
either using a special right triangle or
doing the sine cosine tangent using
those trig functions okay let's look at
a letter F same thing here this is a
special right triangle 45-45-90 triangle
looks like they're giving us one of the
legs okay and that's the side that makes
up the right angle here okay these two
sides are the legs so this side seven
that means that Y is also seven if we
want to get the hypotenuse we just have
to multiply by the square root of two CX
square root of two so that means that X
is going to equal seven square root of
two now you can also do this using the
trig functions you could say sine of 45
equals opposite over hypotenuse so let's
write that down
sine of 45 equals opposite over
hypotenuse multiply both sides by X we
want to get X by itself so I'm going to
divide both sides by sine of 45 and so
you can see ax is going to be seven
divided by the sine of 45 you can do
that in your calculator and it'll give
you you know the approximate value of
the hypotenuse here so that's how you
would work with it either way they're
using the special right triangles or the
trig functions last introductory example
I want to show you before we jump into
some problems you can work on your own
is what we call the angle of elevation
and the angle depression so when we talk
about angle of elevation you can think
of like you're elevating you're looking
up okay and that line of sight so that
angle is in between the horizontal okay
and the your line of sight like that now
angle the
pression you're looking down from the
horizontal okay
so in this case when you do these
problems with the angle elevation angle
depression you can always think of it as
a rectangle
you've got your diagonal of your
rectangle elevation is up from the
horizontal angle of depression is down
from the horizontal notice that these
two angles are actually going to be
congruent because they're alternate
interior angles this is something you
learn in geometry so if this is 40 this
would also be 40 if this is the height
this is also the same height this is a
hundred this is a hundred it's a
rectangle right but in this case let's
say we want to solve for the height of
this tree we don't necessarily want to
climb the tree that could be dangerous
right so we're gonna use our
trigonometry we say well hmm what trig
function ties together the opposite side
and the adjacent side well you can see
opposite and adjacent that's tangent so
what we're gonna do is we're going to
say the tangent of 40 degrees is equal
to the opposite side divided by the
adjacent side so the opposite side is H
the adjacent side is the one next thing
a 100 now all we have to do is multiply
both sides by 100 those cancel and if we
calculate that out let's see we've got a
hundred times a tangent of 40 which
comes out to 83.9 so that's
approximately the height of the pine
tree here that I drew so let me erase
the whiteboard I've got some examples
that you can practice on your own to get
more experience with the right triangle
trigonometry and these sine cosine
tangent ratios and now let's do that
next okay here's your opportunity to
practice so go ahead and pause the video
see if you can do some of these problems
on your own and we'll go through them
together so the first one you can see
we're given this right triangle here and
we want to find the sine cosine tangent
cosecant secant and cotangent and here's
your angle theta so how would you
calculate those trig values well if I
was going to do it I would position
myself over here at the angle that we're
interested in theta and we've got the
sine of theta which remember is the
opposite over the hypotenuse remember so
opposite of hypotenuse so that's going
to be opposite is 12 and the hypotenuse
doesn't want to cross on the right angle
that's going to be 13 if we want to find
the cosecant we just take the reciprocal
as 13 over 12 now the cosine is the
adjacent side over the hypotenuse so
that's going to be 5 over 13 the secant
is just going to be the reciprocal
and the tangent is going to be the
opposite over the adjacent so that's
12:05 cotangent would be the reciprocal
five over twelve and you got it so let's
go to number two now how would you do
this one the cosecant of 30 degrees now
by the way cosecant these are just
abbreviation abbreviations cosecant is
actually cos EC a and T but we
abbreviated CSC so the cosecant of 30
degrees now is what so we're going to
look at our special right triangle here
30 60 90 remember the cosecant is the
reciprocal of the sine so sine is the
opposite over the hypotenuse the
cosecant is going to be the hypotenuse
over the opposite so you can see we have
two x over 1 X the XS cancel and we just
get two okay how about number three the
secant of 45 degrees so we go to our
special right triangle 45-45-90 how
would you do that one secant of 45 well
remember cosine is the adjacent over the
hypotenuse the secant is the reciprocal
it's the hypotenuse over the adjacent so
what we have is X square root of two
over X the XS cancel so we just get
square root of two okay how about number
four how would you do this one so here
we're solving for the missing sine X
what trig function ties together 20
degrees X and eight how would you do
that one well if I was going to do it
you can see that it's the opposite side
and the hypotenuse side so we've got the
sine because remember opposite over
hypotenuse is our sine so sine of 20
degrees is equal to opposite over
hypotenuse if we multiply both sides by
eight you can see x equals eight times
the sine of 20 which I did this earlier
for us this comes out to about two point
seven four okay number five how would
you do this one here you're solving for
the missing side X here we've got the
angle 17 degrees what trig function ties
together 17 degrees 15 and X well if I
was going to do this one I can see that
its opposite and adjacent so opposite
and adjacent that's tangent so we say
the tangent
17 degrees is equal to the opposite side
over the adjacent side now what we can
do here is we can multiply both sides by
X that way that cancels and now we've
got X tangent of 17 degrees equals 15 we
want to get X by itself so we're going
to do the opposite of multiplying by
tangent of 17 we're gonna divide both
sides by tangent 17 and so x equals 15
divided by the tangent of 17 which comes
out to about 49 point one and you got it
so great job review this lesson if you
need to add these formulas to your note
sheet and if you need to review the
lesson otherwise I'll see you in the
next one